[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Sébastien Picot chargé
de programmation à l'association blues
sur scène et Fanny dulsky chargé des
relations publiques et des actions
culturelles bonjour bonjour alors les
deux et trois joints prochain vous
organisez le festival tracteur blues
pourquoi ce nom et quels sont les
objectifs de ce festival alors le projet
du festival tracteur blues en fait c'est
quelque chose qui remonte à plusieurs
années maintenant on prépare la 8e
édition du festival tracteur blues à la
base en fait l'idée c'était de pousser
encore plus loin l'action par rapport à
l'association blue sur scène sur scène
qui se concentre principalement sur les
villes des de la vallée de la Seine de
Mantes-la-Jolie jusqu'à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine et donc de
pousser cette activité en milieu rural
dans des endroits où il y a pas
forcément d'activités culturelles à
l'année ni de salle de spectacle
et donc bah l'idée est venue de là en
fait donc de proposer toute une
manifestation avec
tout un une scène avec les artistes
dessus un village d'artisan des stands
de restauration une buvette voilà et
donc comme à l'époque la seule chose qui
pouvait transporter la scène donc qui
nous est gentiment prêté par la ville de
Mantes-la-Jolie c'était un tracteur du
coup le nom vient de là donc tracteur
aussi pour la ruralité et puis blues
aussi pour faire le lien avec
l'association et ses projets on va
parler de la programmation mais avant
une information importante le festival
est gratuit pourquoi rendre ce festival
gratuit pour que la question du billet
ne soit pas un problème et pour
permettre l'accessibilité au plus grand
nombre après ça nous est possible grâce
aux financement des villes dans
lesquelles on fait le tracteur qui
participe financièrement à l'élaboration
du festival et aussi à nos
subventionneurs un soutien donc
important de ces villes vous avez évoqué
justement le village des donc ou
plusieurs artisans locaux seront seront
présents c'est une façon aussi de
valoriser justement l'artisanat local
tout à fait ben en fait sur le projet du
tracteur blues en fait on essaye
vraiment d'avoir une approche locale
tant au niveau de la programmation que
donc ce fameux village des artisans donc
on contacte chaque année des artisans
locaux et des créateurs afin de leur
proposer un stand où ils peuvent venir
présenter leur production et puis ça se
circuit court continue aussi sur la
restauration travail avec beaucoup de
Food truck
issus du territoire et puis pareil pour
la bière qui est servie au bar donc
voilà on essaie de densité dans cette
idée là de circuit court par rapport à
la manifestation et le festival se
déroule donc le 2 juin à Breuil Bois
Robert et le 3 juin à mes dents pourquoi
l'organiser sur deux communes
différentes parce qu'en fait
l'itinérance est vraiment au cœur du
projet de tracteur blues mais aussi plus
globalement de l'association blue sur
scène et du festival on a envie de
rayonner dans un maximum de villes de
village et donc l'itinérance
possible ce projet ou pour la 8ème
édition du tracteur blues on change de
village mais aussi on en change chaque
année pour le moment on n'a jamais fait
de villages
identiques au tracteur blues et c'est
vraiment ce qui suit le projet du
festival pour nous permettre à nous tous
de découvrir des villages des endroits
et de les mettre en valeur chaque année
et le 2 juin justement le festival ouvre
ses portes à 19h et à 19h30 the best
cave fera alors vibrer le public
qu'est-ce qui définit ce groupe selon
vous et ben the bad cave c'est un groupe
qu'on a rencontré l'année dernière en
fait sur un une soirée qui organisait au
collectif 12 par une un groupe d'amis
qui s'appelle le Bob Dylan day donc
c'est une soirée ou plusieurs groupes du
territoire en fait rendommage à Bob
Dylan en interprétant un ou plusieurs
morceaux et donc ils étaient là sur la
clôture de cette soirée et ce qu'on a
particulièrement apprécié c'est toute
l'énergie en fait qui se dégageait par
rapport à leurs jeux sur scène et donc
c'est un groupe de cover qui sera là
pour présenter un peu les grands
classiques la musique rock blues et
voilà ce qui définit ce groupe c'est
avant tout une énergie sur sur ce projet
et à 20h30 de silitoys un groupe
passionné par la musique pop rock des
années 60 et 90 on va écouter un extrait
on poursuit juste après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et à 21h30 le public pourra découvrir
chorale tapage et à 22h ce sera
l'artiste Thomas Frank Hopper
pouvez-vous nous présenter un petit peu
ces deux concerts et ben la chorale ta
page alors c'est comment dire quand on
travaille sur le tracteur blues en fait
dès les premiers dès le début du projet
on prend contact avec les villes et on
voit un petit peu les ressources dont
ils disposent en fait par rapport aux
artisans par rapport à des associations
locales et puis aussi éventuellement
s'il y a des petites formations amateurs
c'est le cas l'année dernière Nezel on
avait la bande-année elle et donc cette
année à Breuil Bois Robert il y a cette
fameuse chorale tapage dont en tout cas
les les bases sont posées dans cette
ville donc ils auront on aura le plaisir
de les accueillir en fait sur
l'inter-plateau entre le deuxième groupe
et le troisième groupe voilà et pour ce
qui est de Thomas Francoeur donc c'est
un artiste belge qu'on va donc
accueillir pour le final de cette
première soirée c'est un jeune projet
qui commence à démarrer on en est à la
au premier album qui est sorti l'année
dernière voilà moi il me fait un peu
penser à Robert plante au niveau de la
voie avec un guitare un style de jeu de
enfin c'est un spécialiste de la guitare
slide et ça va être vraiment être un
super concert à la fois très très doux
avec quelques envolés assez rock n' roll
donc ça va être une belle date justement
pour résumer un petit peu quelle sera
l'ambiance du 2 juin est-ce que ça sera
la même pour le pour le 3 juin alors on
essaie de travailler sur une diversité
par rapport à la programmation donc
effectivement il y aura des éléments qui
vont être qui vont être un peu
similaires par rapport aux deux dates
dans la mesure où il y a quand même une
bonne partie de la programmation qui est
en lien avec la musique blues donc on
peut trouver des similarités mais sur
des esthétiques des esthétiques qui sont
complètement différentes sur par exemple
Thomas francopper on est sur du blues
rock là ou sur
les Blue foutais de boobies qui
clôtureront la soirée de le lendemain
avec les Blue fever on est sur une
approche beaucoup plus classique au
niveau de la musique donc l'idée c'est
vraiment de travailler sur des
esthétiques différentes de manière à ce
qu'on est un peu pour tous les goûts que
ça le festival soit accessible au plus
grand nombre et on va passer au samedi 3
juin donc à mes dents cette fois à 19h
le groupe haute pause sera en
représentation quelle est l'univers
musical de
ce groupe d'abord est une formation du
conservatoire de Mantes-la-Jolie
conservatoire avec lequel nous avons
l'habitude de travailler chaque année
parce que il est important pour nous
aussi de mettre en valeur les pratiques
d'amateurs donc là forcément le
Conservatoire on a tout de suite pensé à
eux et leur répertoire est assez vaste
il est composé de reprise plutôt rock on
va dire et à 20h c'est le groupe blue
fever qui sera présent à Médan pour le
festival tracteur blues toujours en
écoutant un extrait on poursuit juste
après
[Musique]
on a pu on appuie un petit peu les
découvrir quel est l'univers musical
comment est-ce qu'on peut les définir
musicalement ah bah l'univers musical
d'un groupe comme blue fever c'est des
vieux groupe qui passaient décès les
Rolling Stones c'est vraiment les
classiques de chez classic quoi et c'est
ça qui est vraiment chouette dans un
projet comme ça c'est que il y a une
authenticité en fait qui est défendue
enfin déjà parce que c'est que des
compositions et puis après parce que il
y a une appropriation de tout ce
répertoire et moi ce que je trouve assez
incroyable dans ce genre de groupe c'est
l'alchimie entre les musiciens
on entend quelque chose comme ça on a
l'impression d'avoir une bande de
copains en face de nous et cette manière
de chanter tous ensemble enfin c'est
c'est grandiose je pense que ça va
mettre le feu sur sur scène sur scène
voilà et le festival se termine avec The
Blue foot it gobies pouvez-vous nous
présenter justement ce groupe pour ceux
qui ne le connaissent pas alors c'est
amusant parce que en fait ce groupe les
prémices se sont fait à blues sur scène
en fait on est en 2021 en novembre on
est arrive sur la fin du festival blue
sur scène pour la clôture à l'espace
Jacques Brel de Mantes-la-Ville et en
tout début de soirée on a programmé un
artiste qui s'appelle Ronan qui vient
sur son projet one man band donc Ronan
One Man Band et il nous appelle donc
quelques jours avant et nous demande si
il peut inviter des amis sur cette date
là voilà qu'il a rencontré sur la route
pendant cette tournée
pourquoi pas et donc sur scène en fait
ils ont mis vraiment le feu et le projet
a bien marché ça a bien marché entre eux
et ils ont décidé de monter justement de
manière un peu plus officielle ce groupe
donc il s'appelle les Blue fuets boobies
ils en sont vraiment au tout début il y
a un début de tournée qui s'annonce
cette année il passe notamment au cognac
12 passions cet été et puis ils sortent
leur première album cette année donc là
et ils seront à découvrir donc
exactement blues merci beaucoup
Sébastien Picot et Fanny dulsky d'avoir
été avec nous sur sensation je rappelle
que le festival tracteur Blues aura lieu
donc le 2 juin à breuil-bois Robert et
le 3 juin à mes dents pour plus
d'informations on peut se rendre sur le
site blues sur scène.com et pour revoir
ou réécouter cette émission rendez-vous
sur notre site et notre application
radio sensation
[Musique]